well let's get follicularly challenged
after you well I'm gonna have to shave
my head for this movie at some point to
be honest with you it's something I'm
excited about Patrick it's Bryan Singer
and James McAvoy - to get Patrick via
FaceTime we're about to shave James's
hair this is the moment pal
still got your honor the iconic nature
or Professor X I'm glad to be finally
arriving at that destination
what's my head Oh mate what right here
we go oh boy
oh yes should we go for a mohawk okay
thanks baby we're here just that let me
just keep the male with every piece of
hair that drops
my powers are increasing I have actually
yeah but this is the first time I've
done it's over I'm finally understanding
what it's like to be used really right
probably the moment even more than in
Days of Future past where I felt like he
was handing the baton over he's like
handing the Clippers over
oh thanks Patrick
Santa Serra Patrick Stewart
everything they feel will fall
and from the ashes of their world
we'll build a better one